it's almost Christmas and many of you
are probably planning on praying over
the next few days which is why I want to
take this opportunity to warn you that
if you do plan to pray
and you happen to be in Britain that
could land you in jail
before I ask you any questions about
what's going on today I have to caution
you which is just your rights which is
you do not have to say anything it may
harm your defense if you do not mention
one question something at you later on
in Courtney can you send me
what are you here for today
uh physically understanding here okay
why here of all places I know that we
don't live nearby I think this is an
abortion or something okay
is you standing here part of the protest
no
praying I might be praying in my head
um so I'll ask you once more will you
voluntarily come with us now to the
police station for me to ask you some
questions about today and other days
where there are allegations that you've
broken public
if I've got a choice then okay well then
you're under arrest the class suspicion
of the planning to comply with the
public space it's a protection order
foreign
now I would like to think that this sort
of evil police action cartoonishly evil
police action is only taking place in
the United Kingdom
but it's happening here too the FBI
regularly and increasingly targets
pro-lifers who prey outside of abortion
Mills and then they arrest them on
trumped-up charges that the pro-lifers
are obstructing or intimidating people
who are seeking to kill their children
the UK might be a little bit ahead of
the curve here but not by much people
are being arrested for praying
silently in their heads
and I love my country and I love my
ancestral country Great Britain and I
love my whole civilization and I have
always been raised to believe that we
are the good guys but in recent decades
we've sanctioned the killing of almost a
million babies a year in recent years
we've essentially abolished marriage
we've started grooming and castrating
little kids and pumping them full of
hormones and mutilating their bodies and
now we're arresting Christians for
praying silently in their heads so
I don't want to be a downer or anything
but I've got to ask a very British
question
are we the Baddies are we the baddies
are we the baddies speaking of our
civilization projecting our power abroad
there's a new
there's a new academic report
that the United States Marines have
received
demanding that they stop calling their
drill instructors sir and ma'am
so our Marines are wonderful Brave
Valiant Marines who sacrifice a lot to
defend our country and our way of life
they sign up and they end up working for
these woke lunatics who tell them that
they they can't call their drill
instructors sir or ma'am
because they might misgender the drill
instructor
this according to a 739-page report from
the University of Pittsburgh
this was catalyzed by a new
Congressional mandate so it's our stupid
politicians forcing this nonsense on the
Marines It's featured PhD biologists
Bradley C nindl and Mita lovalecker and
22 academics telling marines that they
need to quote replace gendered
identifiers for instance for example sir
or ma'am in the primary salutation or
response to drill instructors with
gender neutral language such as drill
instructor or senior drill instructor
senior di or SDI
employing gender neutral identifiers
eliminates the possibility of
misgendering drill instructors which can
unintentionally offend or cause Discord
[Music]
we're never going to win another War
again are we we had a good run the U.S
did a pretty good job winning wars for
most of our history
are men and women in uniform or just as
tough as Nails as they always have been
but if the people leading our military
foreign
they're afraid of
misgendering we're not going to win
anymore that's so maybe we've still got
a little bit of Gusto left in us but as
long as long as these military leaders
remain in place we are totally screwed
which is not great because the United
States whether we want to admit it or
not administers a global Empire
we don't make laws like the bill up on
Capitol Hill we're not just little
Nation surrounded by oceans we have a
global Empire we have States overseas
we've got one state Hawaii just in the
middle of the Pacific we have
basically total control over the
European continent because we are the
military for Europe that's what NATO
does We Run The United Nations so we
have a role as the world superpower and
we are currently fighting an Imperial
War
with Russia over the territory of
Ukraine and whether Ukraine will join
NATO or join the European Union or
become part of Russia or maintain a kind
of quasi-independence that that allows
it to be a buffer state to play great
Powers off of one another
you saw this when our vassal Vladimir
zielinski came over to the U.S and
lobbied for more money so that we will
help fund that war against Russia
and the Democrats were happy to have him
they flew him out here to use him and
the the
emotion behind the war in Ukraine to
convince Republicans to vote for this
stupid Omnibus spending package the 1.7
trillion dollar spending package some of
which will go toward funding this war in
Ukraine and one of the images that came
out of this whole
episode was it's a doctored image it's
not it's not an authentic image but it's
an image of Nancy Pelosi and other
congressmen holding up an American flag
but then the bottom of the American flag
is no longer red and white
it's yellow and blue it's the Ukrainian
flag
and the Stars it's no longer all the
stars it's got these little Ukrainian
symbols there too
so it's not it's not a real image
but
it does refer to a real sense I think
all these big Libs changing their
profile pictures and their their names
on social media to include the Ukrainian
flag
which is crazy
I love my family is Italian I love Italy
I'm not going to put an Italian flag in
my handle because I'm an American I'm
not an Italian that's disloyal to do
that
I've got British ancestry as I mentioned
in the open I'm not going to put the
Union Jack in my head because that's but
all these Libs they're putting the
Ukrainian flag and then I was looking at
that I said wow this is the new the new
Imperial standard the red white and blue
with the Ukraine thing at the bottom and
I thought well if we're going to have an
imperial flag
I guess America and Ukraine as a mashup
is better than the current Imperial
standard which is just the pride flag
that is effectively the flag of the
American Empire it's the flag we raise
over our conquered territories overseas
it's the flag that the liberal
imperialists all use they all prefer the
rainbow flag to the red white and blue
it's a flag that denotes not just a
particular place with a particular
people as the American flag does as all
other national flags do but it denotes
Universal values so it it really does
denote a global Empire of liberalism so
you have all of these Libs who use these
kind of flags they never talk about
the nation and the people in the
particular interests of the United
States it's always this abstract stuff
it's always spreading democracy
spreading human rights spreading gay
rights spreading this right in that
right and all these abstract Concepts
all over the world that is a claim of
domination that is a claim of
imperialism saying that individual
Nations have no right to rule themselves
people who have
their own Traditions have no right to
maintain those traditions and this is
the most important part as far as I'm
concerned
even we conservatives here in America
have no right to our own Traditions
Christians here in America here in
Britain here all over the West have no
right to our own traditions we don't get
to go to church they're going to shut
down the churches during covet they're
going to leave the pot stores open
they're going to leave the casinos open
but they're going to shut down the
churches and then even after they reopen
the churches after covid they're not
going to let you pray
silently
outside of an abortion
Clinic that's the problem for me we got
a lot more show coming up it's fake
headline Friday so we have got you I
need your help before you all go to the
airport and miss your flights because
the snowstorm is canceling every flight
in the country before you head down
hunker down and eat some nice turkey or
seven fishes if you're Italian I need
you to help me figure out which is the
fake headline for fake headline Friday
we've also got more voicemail back we've
also got more mailbag mail bag the rest
of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]